Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Lena, es gibt ja jetzt bald Impfstoff. Können wir ja äh bald wieder Feste feiern. Wo wollen wir denn die LNP vierhundert machen?
Mailand oder Madrid, Hauptsache for Seasons.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertachtundsechzig von Freitag, dem dreizehnten zwanzig zwanzig.
Ist auch so ein Datum für die Götter.
Ja, November. Muss man noch dazu sagen. Freitag der dreizehnte November.
Und heute gab's dreiundzwanzigtausendfünfhundertzweiundvierzig Neuinfektionen.
Ja, ja.
Auch keiner. Nerd Infection.
Ja, das ist ähm dreiundzwanzig, zweiundvierzig wäre schöner gewesen, aber wenn man schon da so eine eine Zahl in der Mitte hat, dann wenigstens eine Fünf ist.
Genau. Ja, ich hoffe auch da auf dreiundzwanzig, zweiundvierzig oder irgendwie null werden wir ganz gut, so ein bisschen Zero-Covid äh fände ich ja mal ein ganz geiles Ziel, aber ich glaube, da sind wir noch weit von entfernt.
Siroco ist so wie in Box Zero. Alle reden von aber keiner macht einen Schritt.
Nur Neuseeland haben die das und den Taiwan und.
Man weiß auch wie's geht, ne? Apfel A.
Eigentlich schon, ja. Müssen wir Asien mal fragen, wie die das eigentlich mit ihrer Mail machen? Naja.
Äh
Und gute Nachrichten aus den USA gibt's auch.
Denn vor einer Woche konnten wir uns noch nicht so richtig sicher sein, auch wenn sich das abgezeichnet hat, jetzt ist es, na ja, also fast alle Glaubens außer einem.
Es gibt einen, der es nicht glaubt.
Äh ja, das äh das ist natürlich sehr schön, dass ähm
dieser Wahnsinn, zumindest mal jetzt eine Notbremse bekommen hat, wird wahrscheinlich noch zwei Monate dauern, bis wirklich der Wahnsinn komplett aufhört, aber ich bin zuversichtlich.
Bin ich äh auch. Ich habe dann am, ich glaube, am Samstag war das, ne, dass diese dass diese Meldung kam.
Ach so, wo das erste Mal, ja.
Die Leute zusammen telefoniert und den Champagner getrunken, haben einen schönen Abend gehabt, war äh war war fast so schön, wie ich's mir vorgestellt habe.
Kann man sich, kann man sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht vorstellen, was das für eine Erlösung gewesen sein muss für so eine bestimmte Gruppe von Amerikaner, mit dem wir es bisschen mehr halten, ne, so in New York, insbesondere wenn man sich das angeschaut hat.
Es ist traurig, dass das oder es so ein bisschen schmälert natürlich den Genuss, dass das so ähm.
Ja, so vorsichtig und in Etappen kam und ähm aber ich denke, so tatsächlich mit war dann auch wirklich dann Gott noch alle wieder lachen, weil
Also diesen diesen Gangster Danny Devito da irgendwie auf diesem Hinterhof zu sehen, ja.
Das war wirklich äh das war so, so hat man sich das immer gewünscht, dass es endet, ja und ähm das war dann doch sehr ähm,
das hatte dann doch ästhetischen und kulturellen Mehrwert.
Ja und vielleicht kommt sogar noch das ein oder andere Picture. Da weiß nicht, vielleicht tragen sie ihn ja wirklich irgendwann so Füße nach vorne, nach aus diesem, aus diesem Weißen Haus raus.
Was könnte noch ganz lustig werden.
Ich bin da bin ich tatsächlich gespannt. Da muss man natürlich dann auch nochmal aufpassen mit den ganzen bewaffneten Lunetics so. Ähm.
Aber ich also ich ich beobachte mit sehr großer Spannung.
Das Verhalten der republikanischen Partei, weil die natürlich, also denen müsste ja klar sein, dass sie, also diese Wahl ist jetzt verloren, da werden sie nicht mehr viel dran machen können. Die können aber natürlich noch,
Ansehen, also so viel Zweifel wie möglich an dieser Wahl.
Behalten, streuen und in die in die Legendenbücher eingehen lassen, ja? Und dann müssen sie sich eigentlich überlegen, wer der Kandidat oder die Kandidatin in vier Jahren sein soll und müssen jetzt anfangen, die aufzubauen.
Und die Frage ist, ob sie da, ob sie.
Von ihrem Trump-Film runter sind und ob jetzt einfach mal, sagen wir mal, die ganzen Berufspolitikerinnen dort erkennen, okay, wir müssen jetzt mal wieder einen aus aus unseren Reihen aufgebauten ähm,
ja Parteisoldaten äh irgendwie aufbauen, wenn wir sicher gehen wollen,
auch für uns was vom vom Kuchen übrig bleibt, weil es geht ja auch um die Posten und so. Der hat hier die ganzen hochrangigen äh hochdekorierten Republikaner Veteranen, da irgendwie nur zusammengetreten bei sich im Weißen Haus
und insofern gehe ich eigentlich davon aus, dass die Republikaner Partei sich jetzt über dich jemand Neues aufzubauen, aber noch sich
freuen kann, dass Trump so lange ja das Ansehen beidens äh schädigt, ne? Und aber dann müssen sie irgendwie, glaube ich, brauchen sie einen Exitplan und müssen jemand neues aufbauen. Wenn sie,
Also das hielte ich für die für die sinnvolle Strategie. Kann aber natürlich sein, dass sie sagen, ey bei äh Herbert Walkerbusch hat's auch funktioniert. Ähm.
Wir oder wie wie hießen die Nummer? Doch. Nee, war ja der.
Wer war denn nochmal der, wie hieß der andere? Senior, der hatte doch auch ein Mittelinitial.
Haben die alle, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches.
Ja, bei dem älteren Busch hat's auch funktioniert, dass wir einfach ein von dem nochmal genommen haben, ne? Und ähm.
Ja, genau. Herbert Walker war der W nee, ich werde doch richtig. George Walker Bush war der Alte.
Ist der Alte genau und.
Genau, habe ich doch richtig, habe ich doch richtig gesagt.
Ach so, ja, der andere hieß Walk, einfach nur Walker.
Ja, viel mehr konnte er auch nicht, aber den hat.
Wurde der am Schluss nur noch.
Ja. Ja, genau, denn.
Also ist ein bisschen müßig jetzt sozusagen in die Zukunft zu blicken, zumal und das sollte auch allen klar sein, die eigentlich entscheidende Wahl
steht uns noch bevor?
Im Januar. Denn diese letzten beiden Senatsposten, die dort noch zu vergeben sind, wo ja im Prinzip, die ja beide in Georgia sind, wo jetzt die Demokraten das erste Mal, wie es aussieht, gewonnen haben,
Also wo das Rennen zumindest sehr knapp war, jetzt in der Präsidentschaftswahl, haben die Senatoren halt trotzdem gewonnen, was mich ein bisschen wundert, war, wer stimmt denn auf einmal für Republikaner in dieser Wahl.
Also das ist eben ein bisschen schwierig in die amerikanische Psyche reinzukommen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich jetzt auch grade so ein Staat, wo der
durch diese äh unfassbar
Aktivierung durch diese Stacey Abrahams, die ja im Prinzip letztes Mal schon ihre Gouverneurs Wahl gebracht wurde durch diesen massiven Wahl na ja beruflich, wenn man nicht sagen, aber so diese
Einflussungen, Verhinderung, dass Leute wählen können, die irgendwie achthunderttausend Leute neu registriert bekommen und die wird natürlich in den nächsten zwei Monaten auch nichts anderes tun.
Diese Senatswahlen äh nochmal so richtig unter Feuer zu setzen. Von daher würde ich nicht ausschließen, denn der Vorsprung war ja auch sehr knapp
dass es noch gelingen könnte, zwei weitere demokratische Senatoren in den Senat zu stecken und dann steht's halt fifty fifty
Und das bedeutet in der Arithmetik des äh amerikanischen Kongresses, dass wenn's halt
wirklich auch mal fifty fifty steht in irgendeinem Beschluss und das ist ja sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das passiert, dann entscheidet eben dann die neue Vizepräsidentin darüber, was letzten Endes durchkommt. Und das würde natürlich
Joe Biden die Möglichkeit
geben, auch umfangreichere Formen durchzusetzen, insbesondere was so den Status des äh Präsidenten selber betrifft. Ich denke, da werden jetzt eine ganze Menge Checks und Balances eingebaut werden, die bisher einfach nur Traditionen waren, weil man ja gesehen hat, das funktioniert nicht mehr
und äh gegebenenfalls eben auch neue Regeln, wer denn überhaupt zur Präsidentschafts äh antreten darf so, ne? Und kann auch gut sein, dass Trump halt schon ausreichend vorbestraft ist bis dahin und äh ohnehin nicht antreten darf.
Außerdem will er ja jetzt auch noch einen neuen Fernsehsender auf äh bauen und Fox-News Konkurrenz machen. Das wäre natürlich dann wiederum eine Spaltung des rechten Lagers. Das würden sie eh nicht überleben, weil ohne die Mitte haben sie keine Chance.
Ähm was ein Grund wäre bei Trump zu bleiben für die ähm republikaner.
Die es gibt eine relativ einfache Antwort auf die Frage, warum die Leute vielleicht einen republikanischen Senat wählen und einen äh demokratischen Präsidenten. Ähm das wären ganz einfach
ähm Republikanerinnen mit Anstand. Ja, dass die halt sagen, ich also ich kann Trump nicht wählen.
Aber ich bin natürlich trotzdem
in in der Tradition einer republikaner Familie und ich werde jetzt im Senat dafür sorgen, dass ein beiden in Ketten genommen wird und dass meine Partei möglichst äh die Gelegenheit hat, sich zu zu äh die Wunden zu decken, zu reparieren und mit einer ernstzunehmenden Person in vier Jahren anzutreten.
Schon sein. Also ich meine, das werden wir sehen, äh ob das jetzt alles so demoralisierend äh auf der einen Seite und so motivierend auf der anderen Seite gewirkt hat, um.
Also ist es offen, ich kann's mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass es noch klappen könnte, ich find's super,
Dein Argument zählt und man hat auch gesehen, dieses wie man da so schön im USA mal sagt, diese Party sind Chip, also so dieses Verhaften im eigenen Lager, egal, was dieses Lager letztlich so tut, das ist halt wirklich toxisch. Und
muss man schauen, ne? Letzten Endes brauchen die einfach eine eine Wahlreform, die müssen dieses komische
Elektrol-College abschaffen, weil das ist einfach absurd und na ja, ob das gelingen kann, jetzt mit dem neuen Supreme Court, das ist natürlich nochmal offen. Also, ich mache mir auch nicht zu viel Hoffnung, dass jetzt gleich alles sehr viel besser wird, aber es ist sicherlich schon mal ganz brauchbar, wenn sie
äh jetzt mal so eine halbwegs korrekte und vorhersagbare Außenpolitik haben und mal wieder ihr Statypartment aufpäppeln und überhaupt mal ordentliche Minister erlassen und sich
so International Lorbe kennen und dass dieser ganze Unfug jetzt erstmal vorbei ist. Mein Gott, war das eine Phase, ey Gott, ey.
Es war wirklich zu heulen. Okay, ähm jetzt kommen wir zu anderen Themen, die auch zum Heulen sind und.
Ja, das stimmt. Jetzt schon Schluss mit guten Nachrichten.
Na, eine haben wir noch, eine haben wir noch in petto, bleibt wach, bleibt wach, Kinder.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wir haben uns überlegt, wir wollen den Anlass nutzen, mal ein bisschen, ja, aus einer Meterperspektive über ähm den Kampf gegen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung zu sprechen.
Und Anlass dafür ist, ein Beschluss des EU-Ministerrats ähm, der,
Einen interessanten Titel trägt nämlich Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung, was in Deutschland seit langer Zeit eine Maxime ist, äh die insbesondere aber von ähm.
Ähm wie heißt der Gute, der der Modelleisenbahner Horst Seehofer äh in letzter Zeit wieder äh bemüht wird, im Kampf gegen ähm Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Und ich würde gerne einleitend einmal kurz.
Ja erklären, was endet zur Endeverschlüsselung eigentlich ist, weil man tatsächlich so in den Medien immer noch liest, solche, so, so Formulierungen wie eine besonders gute oder eine besonders sichere Variante der Verschlüsselung oder so
Nee, also diese Formulierung finde ich quasi ein bisschen irreführend, deswegen möchte ich korrigieren. Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung,
ist die einzig brauchbare Verschlüsselung oder jede ähm also jede eine Verschlüsselung muss,
um sinnvoll zu sein, Ende zu Ende sein. Und ich habe mir ein schönes Beispiel dazu ausgedacht, nämlich.
Eine die Kommunikation mit meiner Bank. Ähm wenn ihr.
Also ihr loggt euch beim Online-Banking ein, dann habt ihr eine Verschlüsselung von eurem Browser,
bis zu dem Server der Bank. Und diese Kommunikation ist ja tatsächlich.
Also das das könnte man eine Verschlüsselung nennen. Es ist aber ähm man nennt es man formuliert es eher als eine Transportverschlüsselung. Und der Grund ist folgender.
Was ich bei dieser Bank mache, bleibt also zwischen mir und der Bank, solange,
Ich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht etwas mache, wie eine Überweisung an eine andere Person, unabhängig davon, ob die bei der gleichen Bank ist oder woanders. Und dieser Überweisung,
Einen muss ich ja einen Verwendungszweck geben. Und die Bank.
Diesen Verwendungszweck, ne, die muss denen sogar an andere Banken weitergeben, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine,
Überweisung zu einer anderen Bank mache. Das heißt, meine Kommunikation mit der Bank ist,
Verschlüsselt, ne? Das ist wichtig, um mir meinen Kontostandteil äh die ganzen Authentifizierung und so was zu machen, ne. Authentizierung und so weiter,
Aber wenn jetzt etwas diesen Kontext verlässt, die Bank kann alles sehen. Also alles, was äh die ganze Kommunikation mit der Bank ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, aber Informationen, die den Kontext dieser Bank verlassen.
Sind es nicht. Und in dem Moment, wo meine Kommunikationspartnerin jetzt.
Also bei der gleichen Bank ist oder bei einer anderen Bank ähm hat die, ist die Bank also in der Situation, sie kennt alle Überweisungszwecke, alle Beträge und ähm alle Empfängerinnen von allen Überweisungen.
Bei einer Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung,
würdest du jetzt also würdest du dich darum kümmern, dass jetzt zumindest sagen wir mal der Betrag und der Inhalt ist natürlich bei einer Banküberweisung jetzt unsinnig, aber deswegen machen wir es mal auf den Verwendungszweck, dass der Verwendungszweck nicht für die Bank interpretierbar ist.
Aber für die Empfängerin und das würde tatsächlich sogar gehen, indem man ähm ja, beispielsweise eine PGP-Verschlüsselung nimmt,
ein paar Header abschneidet, damit's noch in das in dieses Feld passt, aber indem man beispielsweise eben den äh Verwendungszweck mit einem bestimmten Knie verschlüsselt und dann so repräsentiert, dass man den über dieses Feld,
transportiert bekommt und dann könnte der Tim beispielsweise den äh Verwendungszweck entschlüsseln.
Mich wird's nochmal kurz ein bisschen anders darstellen noch. Also,
eine Transportverschlüsselung wie TLS, also das, was man gemeint hat als SSL bezeichnet, ist natürlich, wie du schon gesagt hast, eine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung, nur das,
andere Ende ist nicht so weit, wie es sein,
immer besser, umso weiter dieses Ende auch hinten liegt am allerletzten Punkt, wo die Information relevant ist. Und das muss man herstellen.
Genau, also das bedeutet, die Verschlüsselung ist nur, also die Verschlüsselung ist ausschließlich zwischen den beiden Parteien, die es angeht.
Das ist doch eigentlich das Entscheidende.
Wir hatten ja auch diesen schönen äh Fall hier mit DE Mail.
Nehmen wir ja äh ausgiebig ausgekostet haben, wo du ja auch viel äh zu beigetragen hast. Ja, wo dann eben so diese Verschlüsselung eigentlich immer nur so in in Hüpfern stattfindet. Das heißt, es
gab zwar auch Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, nur halt das Ende endet dann halt irgendwo, war dann unverschlüsselt und wurde dann erst wieder im nächsten Schritt weitergereicht. So ist es zum Beispiel auch mit
E-Mail an sich heutzutage. Ne, also ich gebe zwar meine Mail bei einem Mailserver ab.
Aber der kennt den Inhalt.
Ja, aber die landet da unverschlüsselt sozusagen erstmal wieder und wird dann im nächsten Schritt im Idealfall auch wieder mit so einer Transportverschlüsselung zum nächsten weitergereicht, bis es dann endlich mal am,
eigentlichen Ende ankommt so. Auf jeden Fall viel Missverständnispotential in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Jetzt ist es so.
Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung gibt es seit äh sehr langer Zeit, ja. Ähm ich das müssten jetzt so oh
um die dreißig Jahre sein, die das äh die das verfügbar ist, noch nicht ganz so für die Allgemeinheit. Und die ähm
Die schöne Sache an der Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln, was ich hier gerade äh auch so ein bisschen versucht habe, zu erklären mit dem Verwendungszweck, der Überweisung,
kannst prinzipiell über jeden Kanal, der sich dir bietet, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt kommunizieren.
Ne, du kannst das über E-Mail machen, du kannst das über eine Banküberweisung machen, du kannst das über eine Postkarte machen, ne. Alles, was dir eine Kommunikationsmöglichkeit bietet,
bietet dir auch eine Möglichkeit zur Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung. Indem du.
Die Nachricht eben in einem Format schreibst, was äh was eine Verschlüsselung,
ähm ähm einer Verschlüsselung entspricht, ja? Also Verschlüsselung,
um das jetzt sehr kurz zu halten, ist ja auch nur, dass das durcheinander würfeln von Buchstaben und quasi, ne, eine durch eine eine Nachricht mit durcheinander gewürfelten Buchstaben kannst du über E-Mail versenden, kannst du über WhatsApp versenden, kannst du über,
Postkarte versenden. Das Problem ist, daran haben diese ganzen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung immer gekrankt. Deine.
Kommunikationspartnerin muss das auch unterstützen,
was der Grund ist oder was das Problem ist, warum jetzt zum Beispiel PGP niemals großartig abgehoben hat, weil,
eben E-Mail auch ohne gibt. Das heißt, bei jedem, dem du eine E-Mail schreiben willst, musst du dir zusätzlich die Information holen,
ähm ob diese Person ähm Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung,
nutzt und wenn ja, mit welchem Key sie das tut, dann musst du halt irgendwie dir aufm Kieser versuchen, den zu holen, gibt's da ein großes hallo, weil die Leute dann den den Schlüssel zur Entschlüssung nicht mehr haben, also,
wer das mal gemacht hat oder wer das regelmäßig macht, weiß, dass das ein ganz fürchterliches Leid ist. Und,
kam es dann, dass man irgendwann gesagt hat, okay, lasst uns doch Kommunikationssysteme anbieten.
Wo diese Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung schon.
Grundsätzlich mit eingebaut ist. Das heißt, es geht überhaupt nicht über dieses System. Unverschlüsselte Nachrichten zu senden, beziehungsweise,
das es geht schon, aber das User Interface bietet das bietet es einfach nicht an. Ne, das wäre dann ähm.
Der Ansatz, den Threema und Signal, den man hier, denke ich, die.
Pionierrollen in der weiteren Verbreitung ähm für die Allgemeinheit geben muss.
Neben vielen anderen, die es auch gemacht haben und versucht haben und früher versucht haben und so weiter, ähm haben aber so Threema und Signal auf den Mobiltelefon,
den Durchbruch in dieser Richtung gebracht oder dass das den Durchbruch ins Wanken gebracht und dann natürlich mit der Adaptation von,
WhatsApp, dass sie die Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung von Signal sich haben einbauen lassen. Ähm damit war dann so der,
der wirklich der große, große, krasse äh ja ich will sagen,
Dammbruch oder wie auch immer, die Migration der Menschheit zu einer massenhaften Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Kommunikation. Die, das muss man auch ehrlich sagen, davor, für die Masse einfach nicht verfügbar war.
Also
also weil die superpopulären Messenger da eben erst noch nachrüsten müssen. Kleineren, weniger populären System, Schlosserinnen, Systemen gab's, ist auch noch ein bisschen früher, aber
das war auf jeden Fall dann der finale Durchbruch, sagen wir's mal so.
Also du hast Recht, man muss.
Sagen, es war immer für die es war immer für die Masse verfügbar, die Masse hat's nur nicht genommen. Ja, also PGP war auch äh ist immer noch verfügbar und war es äh wie gesagt, müssen jetzt um die müssten bald dreißig Jahre ungefähr sein. Ähm.
War verfügbar, aber weil es eben nicht alle genutzt haben und es halt die eine Sache ist, zu sagen, ey, installierst du Signal? Können wir äh schön sexen? Ähm,
ist halt irgendwie eine andere Sache als installiert, der war PGP, ne, weil das äh.
Eher unsexy.
Naja, das ist so im BDSM Umfeld geht das schon, ne? Aber das sind, wie gesagt, dann eben nicht die Allgemeinheit so, ne? Und ähm na ja.
So und vor diesem,
diese Systeme funktionieren also so, dass sie sicherstellen, dass es bei der bei beiden Kommunikationspartnern einen Schlüssel gibt, der ähm.
Der sicherstellt, dass nur die jeweils die Nachrichten entschlüsseln können. Und eigentlich finde ich das für die Anbieter eine sehr.
Also man muss das auch als eine massiv Risikosenkende Maßnahme sehen.
Für die äh Anbieter. Dass sie nämlich sagen, ey, wenn wir hier die Kommunikation der Welt abbilden, ne, mit unseren paar
dann ist das vielleicht ganz gut, wenn wir diese Inhalte gar nicht sehen können, weil wenn wir dann irgendwann mal gehackt werden, dann können die Hacker auch nicht diese Inhalte sehen
ne? Das ist ja schon eine durchaus ähm kluge,
oder oder eine über eine sinnvolle Erwägung zu sagen, wenn wir als Anbieter mit diesen Inhalten kein Businessmodell haben und und das, was wir eigentlich anbieten halt Kommunikation ist, dann ist das auch wirklich für uns,
massiv Risiko senkende und von Vorteil, wenn wir diese Kommunikation nicht einsehen können. Und vor diesen.
In diesem Hintergrund kommen dann die staatlichen Akteure und sagen ja. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass wir ja diese Inhalte inbegründeten Ausnahmesituationen sehen möchten,
welche Möglichkeiten haben wir denn da? Und sehr simpel gesagt ist es, gibt's.
Also.
Am Ende heißt es, diese Verschlüsselung muss weg, ne. Und ähm Meta gesehen gibt's im Prinzip zwei zwei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Sache, die eine sagt, okay, die Verschlüsselung bleibt, die ist,
Funktional, die wir werden dir auch nicht schwächen. Ähm.
Verändern oder sonst was. Also brauchen wir eine ähm eine Schadsoftware auf dem Gerät der der Absenderin und oder der Empfängerin, die,
die Nachrichten, die dann entschlüsselt sind, ausliest und uns sendet.
Genau oder um bei diesem Bild mit dem mit dem wo ist das Ende äh zu bleiben so? Hinter dem Ende platziert man sich so, bevor die Nachricht gelesen wird.
Genau, daher kommt ja auch dieser Begriff Quellen TKÜ, ne, also die Telekommunikationsüberwachung an der Quelle, bevor es in den bevor es von der Quelle in den Etha fließt, ja? Und die andere Option ist zu sagen, okay.
Wir müssen die Verschlüsselung bitte so machen, dass wir da reinschauen können. Und da gibt es ähm unterschiedliche historische Ideen.
Im Prinzip zu sagen, okay.
Verschlüsselt doch bitte so, dass immer auch ein zweiter Schlüssel mit dabei ist und das ist unserer, für den, für den Intersep.
Ähm das heißt, also äh Tim und Linus können Verschlüsse schicken und es gibt aber noch eine dritte im Bunde,
und das ist die, die Bundesregierung oder das LKA oder oder wer auch immer, ne? Und die machen aber keine Sorge, die machen davon keinen Gebrauch, es sei denn,
Es sei denn, sie müssen, aber sonst könnte hier viel Spaß beim beim äh beim Texten, ja? Ähm die Idee,
Ist historisch, regelmäßig gescheitert, oder Tim?
Ja bisher äh gab's da auf jeden Fall immer ausreichend Widerstand. Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ging das so neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig los.
Man mag sich noch an so Begriffe wie den Clipper-Chip äh erinnern, da war das sozusagen die Idee, dass man äh.
Ryptographische.
Verfahren sowieso erstmal, waren so Export beschränkt und es gab halt einfach entsprechende Auflagen beziehungsweise es würde versucht, hier noch weitere Auflagen zu machen und äh das ging dann eben so weit,
dass die NSA dann eigene Kryptographische Verfahren entwickelt hat, das tun sie ja eh laufen, die sind da ja ganz weit vorne,
und dann ähm die Sache so gedacht hat, dass man eben eine bestimmte Hardware vorschreibt. Ja, das ist dann dieser Klipper äh Chip, ja, der
in die Telefone eingebaut werden soll und das ist dann eben auch
gepaart eben mit dieser Überlegung einer Schlüsselhinterlegung. Das ist so diese dass man äh quasi so einen Masterkey hat von den Behörden, sodass jegliche,
Kommunikation zwar,
erstmal für Dritte, so nicht ähm lesbar ist, ja, aber es gibt dann halt doch noch Dritte, nämlich den Start oder Zweite, die dann eben.
Jederzeit einfach ihren Masterkey nehmen können und sich das dann trotzdem anschauen können. Da gab's dann relativ viel Widerstand dagegen,
die Art und Weise, wie hier argumentiert wird, hat sich eigentlich über die Zeit auch nicht so richtig geändert. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich erstmal ein paar,
praktische Argumente, ja, also allen Leuten jetzt irgendwie eine spezifische Hardware aufzuzwingen, die dann überhaupt nicht
was weiß ich, in den ausreichenden Mengen oder in den ausreichenden Spezifikationen, Stromverbrauch et cetera, Kompatibilität zu anderen Systemen hergestellt werden
kann. Das ist einfach schon mal absurd. Dazu ist die Entwicklung einfach auch viel zu schnell. Man braucht Krypto auch an so vielen Stellen, wo sich nicht ohne Weiteres so eine Hardware integrieren lässt.
Aber das Kernargument ist halt einfach immer.
Wenn ihr so eine Schlüsselhinterlegung macht und dann so ein relativ diffuser Körper wie eine amerikanische Behörde,
Ja oder welche Behörde auch immer, ja, dir potenziell hunderte, tausende, zehntausende Mitarbeiter hat, wenn wenn die dann darauf zugreifen darf
dann ist es halt de facto das Ausschalten der Kryptographie, weil man einfach dann überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, wohin solche Daten gehen. Wir haben ja nun
letzten Jahren auch viele, viele, viele Beispiele bekommen dafür, wie gut so mit Daten
vor allem, wenn sie's um große Mengen handelt, umgegangen wird, wo die dann letzten Endes noch überall hin
beziehungsweise selbst wenn sie nur an einem Ort und so halbwegs ordentlich beschützt wird, wie leicht es dann ist von außen darauf Zugriff zu erhalten, wenn irgendwelche findigen Hacker behördliche Netze ausforschen
und,
diesem Hin und Her der Argumentation äh sind solche Vorschläge eigentlich bisher immer wieder zurückgestoßen worden, weil man einfach sagt, so dann dann haben wir einfach keine Verschlüsselung und der Wert,
hier Verschlüsselung als solche unbrauchbar zu machen im Vergleich zu ähm,
dem dem Wert, den Verschlüsselung für die Gesellschaft und natürlich vor allem auch für die Wirtschaft hat. Das das lässt sich einfach miteinander nicht ordentlich äh abwägen und man schießt sich da einfach selber in den Fuß.
Und ähm diesen diesen Konflikt wird man auch nie,
oder dass dieses Problem wird man nie auflösen und das ist,
denke ich, hier ist aber auch äh genau dieser dieser kluge Ausspruch, den wir ja hier sicherlich auch schon oft wiederholt haben, den wir auch in der äh CCCPM jetzt nochmal wiederholt haben. Wenn man jetzt der allgemeinheit die Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung erschwert.
Dann werden es nur noch wenige tun, das heißt,
ähm ne, wenn man Verschlüsselung kriminalisiert, haben nur noch Kriminelle Verschlüsselung. Denn niemand ist daran gehindert, über egal welchen Kanal
trotzdem in irgendeiner Form eine Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung am Ende doch zu sprechen. Und tja, das ist ähm.
Der Bereich, in dem wir uns befinden.
Wenn jetzt also ähm Regierungen bemühen.
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung anzugreifen. So, jetzt stellt sich die Frage, für welchen Weg haben sie sich denn entschieden?
Und das ist aus unserer äh dieser, wenn man aus dieser traditionellen Debatte kommt, ne, ist entweder Schadsoftware oder kaputte Verschlüsselung. Ähm.
Ein neuer Weg, nämlich dass sie eigentlich sagen, wir möchten.
Dass die Schadsoftware von den Anbietern selber möglichst.
In die Software eingebracht wird. Also wir wir möchten.
Potentiell verzichten, Staatstrojaner irgendwo anbringen zu müssen?
Wir möchten potenziell verzichten, die Kryptographie in ihrer Qualität zu senken.
Also möchten wir einfach ein spezifisches Update für unsere Zielperson oder eine spezifische Funktionalität für unsere Zielperson.
Dass da die Nachrichten nochmal ausgeleitet werden. Und das ist.
Natürlich etwas, was die Anbieter nicht von sich aus tun werden. Ja, weil deren Kern Businessmodel ist ja zu sagen, wir haben,
Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation. Du kannst uns vertrauen, weil du uns nicht vertrauen musst. Und das hat eben zu der Beliebtheit dieser Messenger,
beigetragen. Übrigens ähm auch die Europäische Kommission empfiehlt ja spezifisch,
die Nutzung von Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Messengern an ihre ähm Angestellten. Ja und sagt, ey Leute bitte, wenn ihr irgendwie hier mit Leuten kommuniziert, nutzt doch mal ähm
nutzt doch mal bitte Signal. Ja, also die sind sicher selber sehr bewusst.
Der des Schutzes und der Sicherheit, die diese ähm.
Die diese Messenger bieten. Und um jetzt mal kurz.
Die Eleganz dieses Ansatzes zu würdigen, die Anbieter zu zwingen, muss man halt sagen, ne,
die meisten Menschen nutzen halt, ne, was weiß ich, ein iPhone oder ein Android-Telefon mit den Apps aus dem Store und damit sind die happy und fertig. Und
würde man nun sagen, okay, wir verpflichten die Anbieter bei Bedarf eben eine Vektor als Update zu pushen oder zu aktivieren als Feature.
Dann spart man sich immerhin die Debatte um.
Das Aufbewahren von Schwachstellen zur Infektion dieser Geräte. Das heißt, aus einer Perspektive oder aus der Perspektive der inneren.
Sicherheit, Leute. Ist das,
die der so die Quadratur des Kreises, weil sie sagen, super, alle behalten den Schutz der Verschlüsselung, die wird nicht geschwächt. Es gibt eine spezifische Vektor für uns, wenn wir die benutzen möchten.
Aber zumindest wir als Bundesrepublik Deutschland und deren strafverfolgende Behörden schießen uns nicht ins eigene Knie.
Leider ist das falsch und zu kurz gedacht, weil wenn die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
oder die Europäische Union oder die USA, diese Anbieter verpflichten, Abhörschnittstellen zu bauen, dann
tun das natürlich auch andere Länder, ja? China
reibt sich doch schon die Hände und sagt, super, dann können unsere Leute hier demnächst auch äh von von uns aus WhatsApp benutzen, wobei die haben ja aufgrund ihres Weethots überhaupt gar kein Interesse äh WhatsApp zu benutzen, aber ihr seht,
wohin das Argument geht. Das heißt, die verlieren äh sehr wohl auch den.
Der Verschlüsselung und sie sorgen sehr wohl eben zu, führt zu diesem Problem, sie sie tragen zu dem Problem bei, dass Verschlüsselung
genau an den Stellen, wo sie sie interessiert, wo nämlich Menschen wissen, okay, krass, ich bin ja Terrorist,
oder ich bin was weiß ich Kriminelle genau diese Menschen werden natürlich weiterhin,
zusehen, dass sie eine Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Möglichkeit finden zu kommunizieren. Und sei es, dass sie die selbst über irgendeinen anderen und verdächtigen Kanal kloppeln. Das heißt.
Schaden auch mit diesem Vorstoß,
nur der Allgemeinbevölkerung, nicht aber denjenigen, die sie damit so angeblich verfolgen möchten. Und es geht noch weiter, dadurch, dass sie jetzt deine, deine Vertrauten.
Anbieter,
zwingen, deine Kommunikation abhörbar zu machen, obwohl ihr eines Younique Selling Feature war, dass das nicht möglich ist.
Dadurch zerstören sie natürlich das Vertrauen, dass du noch überhaupt irgendwie in diese Anbieter haben kannst. Ähm wenn also jetzt Apple verpflichtet ist, zu sagen, wir backdorn Tims iPhone ähm.
Bei Bedarf würde ich schätzen, dass Tims Apple Enthusiasmus einen leichter Dämpfung erfahren würde.
Weiß man noch nicht so genau. Also ich meinte.
Vorstellbar.
Ähm und ja, darum.
Geht es in dieser Debatte und darum ist es so wichtig, dass zurückzuweisen und zu verhindern, weil es letztendlich um nicht mehr und nicht weniger geht, als den einen.
Vertrauensanker und Schutz, den uns.
Ja Internet und Computer bieten. Ja, also wenn es diese kryptographischen Prinzipien nicht gäbe.
Ähm dann.
Hätten wir also wahrscheinlich hätte alles, was ihr an Digitalisierung irgendwie großartig seht und äh feiert und euch dran erfreut, das gäbe es dann nicht, wenn wir diese Verschlüsselung nicht hätten.
Das wir komplett unbenutzbar. Also es gab vielleicht mal so eine Zeit, da ging das noch so, weil da einfach noch ein nicht ausreichend viele Leute drauf äh gekommen sind, wie viel Schaden man da anrichten kann. Aber wenn du heute äh jegliche Verschlüsselung ausschalten würdest, kannst
im Prinzip das Internet auch wieder abschalten. Also dann ist einfach vorbei. Das ist so richtig komplett vorbei.
Nur so ein bisschen vorbei, sondern so kann man einfach sofort sein lassen.
Ja, ich meine, auch diese Annahme, dass jetzt so eine staatliche Behörde irgendwie besonders vertrauenswürdig wäre. Ich meine, das haben wir ja irgendwie
hohe Zahl an Einzelfällen, ja, die die man schon fast.
Ähm kann man schon fast den Kalender äh mit ersetzen, weil jeder Tag ordentlich durchgezählt wird und immer wieder neue Einzelfälle kommen
Also das dann so so eine so eine Polizei oder so ein Geheimdienst, der sich einfach jetzt nicht gerade mit Rum bekleckert hat in den letzten Jahren, ganz im Gegenteil, wo es einfach
nachweislich immer wieder ein hohes Maß an Unterwanderung und Kontakte zu wirklich hoch problematischen Subgruppen dieser Gesellschaft gibt,
die dann auf einmal äh einen ungehinderten Zugang bekommen sollen? Weiß ich nicht, also einem Notkonvinz, dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Also da merkt man ja schon, wie wie das Misstrauen hier in einen hineinkriecht, weil es halt einfach klare Belege dafür gibt, dass dass dieses Misstrauen auch begründet ist.
Ja, absolut.
Und dann ähm nochmal der, also dann kommt ja noch ein anderer Aspekt, ne, die Kompetenz deutscher Umsetzung im Tech Bereich, da kannst du ja davon ausgehen, dass in dem Moment, wo die irgendwelche Piktos für WhatsApp haben, dass das äh.
Das halt nicht mehr lange dauert, bis A die, wie du schon sagst, missbraucht werden, aber auch B bis die irgendwie aufgemacht und äh gehackt werden, ja? Und dann hast du dann siehst
stehst du da und ich muss an dieses ähm ich muss da immer an dieses Mehm denken, kennst du diesen, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt. Diese, es ist so eine Cartoon
wo jemand sich einen Stock hat und den bei seinem bei der Fahrt bei seinem Fahrrad in die vorderen Speichen hängt und sich dann daneben licht und meckert,
Ja, und sich dann beschwert, dass ihm das Knie weh tut. So, so ungefähr kommt mir das wirklich ähm äh diese diese Herangehensweise.
Vor und ich glaube, dass das also ich kann nur fest sagen, das wird nur.
Negative Effekte haben und vor allem, und das ist das katastrophale, noch nicht einmal die Intendierten,
ja? Das ist das, was man sich hier sehr wichtig im Hinterkopf halten muss, wenn man mit Leuten diskutiert, die äh meinen nichts verbergen zu nichts zu verbergen zu haben, muss sehr klar sagen.
Selbst wenn du nichts zu verbergen hast und selbst wenn du es völlig okay findest und selbst wenn du negierst, dass das ein Schaden für die Vertraulichkeit ähm der Kommunikation aller ist und dass das potentiell wirtschaftliche ähm,
Schäden hervorruft und international stellt. Wenn du das alles negierst, musst du immer noch sagen.
Okay, aber den versprochenen positiven Effekt, dass irgendwie Kriminelle nicht mehr verschlüsseln können, denen wird's schon mal nicht haben. Das ist die eine Sache, wo du sicher sein kannst,
diesen Effekt wird es nicht haben. Maximal auf, sage ich mal, die ähm die mit.
Also die, die's, die, die's auch auf andere Weise geschafft hätten, sich irgendwie in den Knast zu bringen. Ja und ähm insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund.
Also veröffentlicht wurde das Vorhaben des EU-Ministerrates ja durch Erich Möchel haben wir glaube ich hier schon öfter gewürdigt als ein,
Titanen der netzpolitischen Berichterstattung, wenn nicht sogar einfach der Gründer der netzpolitischen Berichterstattung. Ähm.
Er schreibt, nach dem Anschlag kommt der Angriff auf die Verschlüsselung und,
stellt das hier in den, klar in den, in den zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit diesem Terroranschlag in Wien.
Gleichzeitig wissen wir aber auch durch die Diskussion, die wir hier seit Wochen über Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung führen, dass es diese Bestrebungen schon länger von allen Seiten gibt und vor allem aber,
ist der Anschlag von Wien ja so enorm,
ungeeignet, als Argument zu dienen für einen Angriff auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, weil A, der Typ
polizeibekannt war, die wussten sogar, dass der sich da irgendwo knarren gekauft hat und haben die Hinweise ignoriert, ähm die konnten innerhalb kürzester Zeit, nachdem sein, nachdem er irgendwie bekannt war, konnten die, ich glaube,
waren das achtzehn. Ich habe irgendwie achtzehn im Kopf. An achtzehn Orten in äh Europa, Deutschland, Schweiz und so. Ähm
Seine Kontakte und äh primären Bezugspersonen irgendwie hochnehmen.
Das heißt, sie wussten schon alles über den Typen. Der noch dazu ein Einzeltäter war,
ähm wo man jetzt natürlich auch wiederum sagen muss so, ne, was wird so ein Einzeltäter schon kommuniziert haben? Ähm also es gibt hier nicht den, ne, man kann das Argument nicht bringen.
Dass dieser Anschlag hätte verhindert werden können, wenn die die österreichische Polizei,
Doch nur U1 in seine verschlüsselte Messenger-Kommunikation gehabt hätte. Dieses Argument ist nicht ähm also das besteht den Lachtest,
solange man so nicht, ne? Also wenn man in diesem Bereich noch einen Lachtest machen kann, weil das ist ja tragisch genug, wie die den Typen haben, ja, letztendlich unter ihren Augen problemlos wirken lassen.
Sag mal, schickst du dir nicht die ganze Zeit äh deine eigenen Ideen, dir selber per Nachrichten zu? So per SMS.
So no to self, ne.
Genau.
Vergessen, Freitag Anschlag.
Absurd.
Naja und das ist ähm.
Also warum wir dieses Thema jetzt auch nochmal mit dieser Ausführlichkeit und dieser Dringlichkeit besprechen, hat ein bisschen damit zu tun, dass,
einfach jetzt von zu vielen gefordert wird, ne? Es wird von den Five-Eis gefordert, zusammen mit Japan und Indien. Es wird.
Von dem EU-Ministerrat gefordert, die deutsche Bundesregierung hat gerade wieder Vorstöße in diese Richtung über unternommen und man merkt so ein bisschen, dass die alle jetzt grade so an dem Punkt sind zu sagen,
Okay, komm, jetzt, jetzt ist unser Moment, ne? Jetzt müssen wir alle, jetzt halten wir das Thema in den Medien und jetzt, jetzt pushen wir das durch. Und jetzt ist der wichtige Moment, sich dem entgegenzustellen und ich.
Habe die Sorge, dass potenziell ähm.
Also im Moment noch nicht genug Protest und genug Aufmerksamkeit in diesem Bereich da ist. Daher äh wirklich,
versuchen wir mit dieser Folge euch genug ähm Erklärung nochmal gebündelt zu bieten, dass ihr,
auch Menschen, die vielleicht sagen, dieses Thema interessiert sie nicht,
davon ähm unterrichten und ihnen erklären könnt, worum es dabei geht, ähm dass ihr vielleicht diese Folge auch ähm anderen Leuten empfehlen könnt, wenn ihr sagt, okay, bei denen komme ich nicht weiter,
Wobei das jetzt blöd, wenn die Leute das jetzt auch hören, weil weil ihr denen was Gutes tun möchtet, weil ihr die so schätzt, ja, dass sie eine schöne Folge hören können, dann könnt ihr sie denen empfehlen.
Und ich muss tatsächlich sagen, hm, also wenn das kommt.
Dann wird das also das wird sehr sehr äh sehr sehr unschön. Das wird sehr sehr im im im auf lange Perspektive sehr unschöne ähm Konsequenzen haben, weil.
Wenn
dieser Damm einmal bricht, ne, wenn man jetzt irgendwie sagt, also ne, die Sachen laufen ja äh Terrorismus und dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch sind das, wo wo wir uns drum kümmern müssen und dann geht's halt in drei, drei Jahren weiter mit,
Urheberrechtsverstößen und so weiter und dann hast du irgendwann.
Vollzeitmonitoring auf deinen äh auf aller deiner digitalen Kommunikation und,
vielleicht um das nochmal zu sagen, äh.
Kommunikation ist ja tatsächlich inzwischen der geringere Anteil des Datensatzes, den wir als Menschen produzieren. Ja? Wir produzieren ja am laufenden Band irgendwelche Google Maps Abfragen und,
Facebook Likes und Instagram haste nicht gesehen und
Tinder swipe nach links, swipe nach rechts und was nicht alles, ja, alle diese Daten produzieren wir ja sowieso ähm jede mit jeder Sekunde oder jeder Minute unseres Lebens.
Und Kommunikation das kleine bisschen, was wir jetzt hier ähm verschlüsseln wollen, ist der geringste Anteil daran. Noch dazu ähm.
Wir haben ja auch relativ viel zu zu Zeiten Snowdens ähm darüber gesprochen.
Dass äh Metadaten.
Schon die entscheidenden Daten sind, ne, dieser schöne Aufkleber wird uns verraten, Meterdaten ähm,
Das ist das, wo worum du dir eigentlich äh Sorgen machen musst, weil sie also als als Krimineller, ne, weil sie ähm,
automatisiert auswertbar sind, weil sie dein soziales Netz, deine Bewegung und so weiter zeigen und das ist äh nach, denke ich, gängigen,
und auch an den regelmäßigen Erfolgen der Polizei erkenntlich. Ähm.
Eine ein sehr reichhaltiger ähm Fundus an Informationen, die dadurch zu erlangen sind, sodass jetzt die Kommunikationsinhalte bei der ähm.
Bei der Interpretationsinterpretierbarkeit der Daten schon eine untergeordnete Rolle spielen. Erkennt man ja auch daran, dass WhatsApp immerhin ja auch ein Facebook-Konzern bereit war,
diese Kommunikationsinhalte Ende zu Ende zu verschlüsseln, ja? Also die Datenkrake äh um das Bild mal zu bemühen, sagt, ja okay, pass auf, die Daten brauchen selbst wir nicht,
Wir haben genug. Das kleine bisschen können wir denen lassen.
Können wir den Begriff Datenkrak nochmal beerdigen, finde ich furchtbar.
Ja, ich hab's extra, ich wollte das jetzt ein bisschen spaßeshalber anwenden, aber ja, der Begriff ist ähm nicht
nicht äh angemessen. Aber ähm sagen wir mal die, deren deren Geschäftsmodell, das Sammeln äh auswerten ähm und verwerten von Daten ist, haben freiwillig,
diese Kommunikationsinhalte verzichtet. Und das sollte einen dann schon äh stutzig machen, weil das sind ja echt diejenigen, die oft nix verzichten.
Kraken übrigens schon, ne? Kraken sind eigentlich relativ genügsame Tiere.
Oder intelligent.
Ja, die würden so einen Scheiß nicht machen.
Genau.
Sei nicht wieder Innenminister, sei wie Herr Krake.
Okay.
Ich denke äh oder ich hoffe, wir haben damit äh dem dem Kampf um die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung und das ist, denke ich, der Kern dessen, was ich sagen möchte, das ist nicht der Kampf um die Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung, das ist der Kampf um überhaupt Verschlüsselung.
Und der ist der fundamentale Vertrauensanker.
Der digitalen Kommunikation und des Netzes und wenn es hier irgendwie nochmal vorangehen soll, dann brauchen wir mehr Verschlüsselung und nicht weniger.
Muss man ganz klar sagen, wir brauchen mehr Verschlüsselung und nicht weniger und ich möchte da jetzt ja vielleicht doch noch ganz kurz dieses, das Wirtschaftliche Argument bringen.
Große Unternehmen und große kriminelle Organisationen werden immer in der Lage sein, sich eine sichere Verschlüsselung irgendwie zu kaufen.
Es geht immer darum, was der Allgemeinheit einfach verfügbar ist. Und nur der Allgemeinheit äh würde es genommen und soll es genommen werden. Und das ist der Grund, warum,
äh
es hier um einen Vorstoß geht, wo wir, genau wir, die ähm was sind wir denn? Die rechtschaffenden, die rechtschaffenden Bürgerinnen, die nichts zu verbergen haben.
Die Guten, genau, die Guten. Wo wir, die Guten, äh, einen Schaden nehmen.
Niemand anderes. Ja, also es, es, wir kriegen, wir gewinnen da nichts. Wir haben da nur Verlust, nur Schaden und das äh da muss sich eigentlich jede, jede Person muss sich hier vom Kraken überzeugen lassen, dass das nix ist.
Hast du das Gefühl, den Leuten schon genug Angst gemacht zu haben? Ich sag's mal anders. Ohne Verschlüsselung, keine Podcasts. Jetzt Panik.
Äh
Jetzt rennen sie alle schreiend durch die Flure. Nein.
Aber das ist ein, ja, ja, genau. Soll das, ist das eine Drohung oder.
Das haben wir jetzt mal so gesagt, ne? Und das wird schon seine Wirkung entfalten.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir machen noch ähm.
Wir weisen noch kurz auf ähm eine.
Ähm Kampagne hin, die Etri, unsere Freunde von European Digital Rights gelauncht haben, nämlich ähm die Kampagne Reclaim your face. Ähm was ich sehr ähm.
Sehr interessant finde, wo sie im Prinzip sagen, okay ähm wir wenden uns gegen Biometrie,
Also biometrische Massenüberwachung, insbesondere die
Gesichtserkennung, die daran ähm gebunden ist. Auch darüber haben wir hier schon sehr oft gesprochen. Du kannst dein biometrisches Merkmal nicht ändern. Ähm,
Deshalb ist es eigentlich auch als Authentizierungsmerkmal enorm ungeeignet. Es ist aber enorm gut geeignet als Überwachungs ähm Merkmal, weil.
Wenn die Pandemie vorbei ist, alle wieder ohne Maske rumrennen wollen. Und dann wäre es halt sehr ungünstig.
Wenn es eine biometrische Vollüberwachung äh gäbe. Insofern ähm strengt sich diese Kampagne an.
Für Transparenz,
zu sorgen, was eben, ne, warum biometrische Gesichts- und Massenüberwachung überhaupt gebaut wird und welche Funktionen sie hat. Äh rote Linien zu ziehen, wo man sagt, wo darf das nicht stattfinden.
Und ähm auch die Experimente damit, die ja zum Beispiel hier auch in Berlin am Südkreuz äh stattgefunden haben.
Zu beenden und denen entgegen zu treten.
Und äh ich denke, das ist ein äh sehr wichtiger ähm Kampf, da jetzt für ein Moratorium zu sorgen. Diese Technologie einzuheben, wie das zum Beispiel, ich glaube in San Francisco schon geschehen ist, denn,
Ich habe gerade gesagt, mit der Verschlüsselung würde das letzte bisschen.
Digitaler Überwachung sterben, dass wir im digitalen Raum haben. Mit der biometrischen Erfassung geht diese digitale Überwachung in.
Unseren in den nicht in den nicht digitalen Alltag, ja? Das ist also, darf man sich in seinem Ausmaß, kann man sich das gar nicht.
Kann man das gar nicht überschätzen, wie krass diese Überwachungsmöglichkeit wird. Es macht eben,
für dich als Mensch, der da langgeht, kaum erkennbaren, aber es macht einen für die Überwachungsmethode sehr entscheidenden Unterschied, ob du,
irgendwo eine Kamera hängen hast? Oder ob an dieser Kamera ein Gesichtserkennungssystem ist, was sofort sagt, ach, alles klar, das ist der Neumann, äh der ist gerade vor der Kamera in die Kamera gelaufen und der ist heute Morgen äh bei sich zu Hause losgegangen und dann das,
nämlich,
aus dem großen, komplexen Videodatenstrom hier eben sehr einfache, strukturierte Daten zu erlangen, nämlich Metadaten.
Und das ist auch alles nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass man so ein Verbot erwirken kann. Das hat ja äh wenn ich jetzt so richtig informiert bin in Kalifornien, auch schon stattgefunden. Da gab.
Genau, ich meine, ich ich meine es wäre nur San Francisco gewesen, ich weiß aber nicht. Äh vielleicht war's auch der ganze Staat.
Ja, okay, da bin ich jetzt gerade nicht ganz newsfest, aber äh da gibt es auf jeden Fall
ein Trend und ähm ich denke auch, dass so Facebook äh einem relativ klar macht, wenn man das benutzt, äh wohin das gehen kann. Dieses Problem, man wird halt von irgendjemanden aufm
Bild getagt und so und ja und andere Leute erfahren dann, wo ich war, weil ich auf irgendeiner Veranstaltung noch war. Ja, klar, das sind dann oft erstmal nur bewusste äh Tackings, dass Leute sagen, ja hier, das ist der Tim,
Ja, aber in dem Moment, wo halt eine weitverbreitete äh Datenbank und wir hatten ja hier diesen Fall von diesem Unternehmen, wie hießen die noch, gleich,
irgendwas, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, die äh.
Ay oder was.
Ja, genau, die halt sozusagen Dritten einfach so Zugriff auf solche
ähm Datenbanken geboten hat. Äh dadurch kann man halt schnell in einem beliebigen äh Bildmaterial das alles heraufbringen. Und das kann natürlich alles zu Problemen, zu Missverständnissen, familiären Problemen, beruflichen Problemen führen, ne? Und,
Das äh sollte einfach nicht sein. Das ganze Problem von Überwachung an sich ist ja auch immer eigentlich ein.
Eine Frage des Preises tatsächlich
Früher gab es diese Ideen ja auch schon, Rastafanung, so dass äh also massenhaft Daten sammeln und dann mal durchschauen, wird sich schon irgendwas finden lassen. Diese Ideen sind nicht neu, nur sie sind,
eigentlich im Wesentlichen immer nur daran gescheitert, dass es nicht bezahlbar war.
Man hat sich das vorstellen können, man wollte das irgendwie haben. Wir haben aber jetzt in unserem in unserer technologischen Entwicklung weltweit einfach eine,
unglaubliche Preisreduzierung gesehen. Also lange Zeit war so dieses ja
kann man überhaupt ein Gesicht erkennen? War schon mal eine Frage. Das war dann irgendwann beantwortet und man braucht da natürlich einen dicken Rechner dafür und dann hat er irgendwie drei Stunden lang auf einem Bild rumgerechnet. Dann stimmte das so zu sechsundsiebzig
Prozent. Davon sind wir mittlerweile weit entfernt. Mittlerweile gibt es Hochdedizierte kleine äh Chips, die das irgendwie für wenig Geld massenhaft in äh
kurzer äh Zeit realisieren können. Und es wird halt immer billiger,
das massenhafte Überwachen von Telefonaten, von Audio, von Video et cetera. Das ist halt.
Irgendwie bezahlbar geworden und weil das eben bezahlbar wird, kommen dann eben diese alten Träume von, na ja, immer her mit dem Heuhaufen. Die Nadel werden wir schon irgendwie finden. Die kommen dann halt äh noch mit dazu
Und dabei wird halt einerseits übersehen, dass es eben
Auch wenn es äh scheinbar billiger ist, am Ende natürlich für die Gesellschaft trotzdem noch ein äh hohe Kosten aufwirft, jetzt konkret
Geld, ja, aber am Ende der eigentliche Schaden an der Gesellschaft selbst äh verunstaltet wird, weil einfach in diesem Prozess uns viele
wichtige, nennenswerte Freiheiten genommen werden, weil sie ja dann am Ende,
Also selbst wenn man jetzt nicht so dieses Szenario gleich äh hervorholt mit
oh Gott, ich werde hier irgendwie als Bankräuber erkannt von irgendeiner Software und das werde ich ja nie wieder los und dann habe ich jahrelang Rechtsstreit, solche Einzelfälle gibt es, aber das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt jetzt für die meisten Leute das Problem
Das Hauptproblem, denke ich, was daraus resultieren würde, ist.
Dass man sich einfach zurückzieht, dass man sich einfach, dass man einfach bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr tut und äh einfach zurecht dann auch glaubt, man wäre einfach die ganze Zeit verfolgt und äh dass dann eine entsprechende
Anpassung des eigenen Verhaltens bringt, die man eben sonst nicht tun würde. Und um diese,
die Handlungsfreiheit einem zu erhalten, allen zu erhalten, denke ich, ist es extrem wichtig, dass man einfach das Prinzip umdreht und sagt.
Nee, der Deal ist, ist nicht erlaubt. Es sei denn, das und nicht,
somit, ihr könnt ja machen, was ihr wollt und,
Hat mal einer total über die Stränge geschlagen. Das verletzt jetzt irgendeinen äh drittes äh Gesetz, so dann hauen wir da vielleicht mal ein bisschen drauf,
das verhindert halt irgendwie gar nichts. Sondern die Vorhaut muss wirklich anders herum sein und man muss
Organisationen, Firmen, wen auch immer, auch Privatpersonen quasi in äh die Situation bringen, dass sie
dass sich quasi erlauben lassen müssen
und dass sie das dann entsprechend belegen müssen. Warum muss das so sein? Überwachungskameras hängen mittlerweile an jeder Dachrinne
und ich kann mühelos mit so einem, mit so einer billigen Webcam einfach auf die Straße zielen und anfangen, irgendwelche Gesichter zu erkennen,
Das wird dann halt auch getan werden. Und bei öffentlichen ähm bei dem bei der Überwachung des öffentlichen Raums wird's halt richtig knifflig, weil,
da kommt dann jeder irgendwie mal dran vorbei. Und das ist einfach, das einfach das ist einfach kein Envarment, in dem in dem ich leben möchte. So geht einfach nicht.
Deswegen muss es umgedreht werden.
Ergänzung. Ähm es war erst San Francisco und dann der Start Californien, die äh eben die Verwendung von Gesichtserkennungstechnologien für ihre Behörden ähm untersagt haben.
So, dann kommen wir zur guten Nachricht. Ja, ja oder?
Ach echt? Jetzt schon? Na, Kurve. Ja, machen wir das.
Wir erinnern uns, dass unsere Freunde von frag den Staat ähm das Glyphosat-Gutachten,
des Bundesinstituts für Risikobewertung veröffentlicht hatten und beziehungsweise der der ein Streit darüber entbrannte, ob dieses Werk, was man im Rahmen einer ähm.
Einer äh eines äh Informationsfreiheitsanfrages äh bekommen kann.
Ob das dann auch auf frag den Staat selber eingestellt werden kann und die haben gesagt, nee, das nicht, weil wir haben ja ein Urheberrecht da dran und das wird dieses Urheberrecht wird verletzt, wenn ihr,
das hier auf diese Seite stellt. Also das, die haben quasi argumentiert, jede kann das bei uns anfragen und bekommt das dann auch. Aber,
ihr dürft es nicht online stellen.
Und was fragt den Staat, da mal daraufhin Mitte ähm zwanzig neunzehn gemacht hat, war, sie haben,
also sie wurden erstmal gezwungen, vom Landgericht Köln dieses Glyphosat-Gutachten von ihrer Webseite zu nehmen, ne? Daher kam dann so dieser Begriff Zensurheberrecht, weil,
quasi die, ihre Veröffentlichung eines für die Öffentlichkeit interessanten ähm Dokuments, was man auch jede einzelne Person,
bekommen darf über eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage, aber die Veröffentlichung wurde ihnen quasi untersagt.
Und dann haben sie äh dazu aufgerufen, dass man sich dieses Gutachten bestellt und es haben fünfundvierzigtausend weitere Menschen über frag den Staat das Gutachten angefragt, ja und auch bekommen,
und.
Jetzt kommt äh der spannende äh Teil, dass sie damit mit der Veröffentlichung im Februar zwanzig neunzehn keine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen haben. Unter anderem.
Äh ich zitiere jetzt, was das so schön ist, äh der Grund, weil das Bundesinstitut nicht nur uns, sondern nach unserer Anfrage auch mehr als fünfundvierzigtausend weiteren Menschen das Gutachten zugesandt hat.
Ja
Hat das Gutachten laut Landgericht Köln seinen urheberrechtlichen Schutz verloren. Es ist so vielen Menschen zugänglich gemacht worden, dass es laut Gericht als veröffentlicht gelten kann,
Es gilt jetzt als amtliches, also uneingeschränkt nutzbares Werk. Ähm was sehr interessant ist, weil es natürlich eine Falle ist. Wenn das äh
Also das Bundes äh Institut den anderen fünfundvierzigtausend Anfragen dann gesagt hätte, nee, ihr kriegt das nicht, dann hätten sie gegen das ähm.
Im Zweifelsfall gegen das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz verstoßen und hätten erklären müssen, warum sie ähm,
an der ersten Anfrage das geschickt haben und anderen das nicht schicken.
Und dadurch, dass sie es so vielen geschickt haben, konnten sie jetzt den Anspruch des Urheberrechtes äh des Urheberrechtlichen Schutzes nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten gegenüber der Veröffentlichung. Ähm was ich äh erstmal so als als rechtliche ähm,
Falle, ja, oder als äh als rechtliche, äh wie nennt man denn sowas? Falle, ne.
Weiß ich nicht.
Als rechtliche Zwickmühle, genau, eine Zwickmühle ist das. Da jetzt rechtliche Zwickmühle sehr sehr schön gespielt finde.
Ähm gleichzeitig muss man natürlich trotzdem sagen, es ist immer wieder äh eine Katastrophe, wie viel äh fragt den Staat klagen muss, einfach nur auf eine einfache Einhaltung von Gesetzen und ähm ja vielleicht hat das,
Bundesamt hier das Bundesinstitut ja hier auch verstanden wenn sie dieses Glyphosat-Gutachten einfach da auf auf frag den Staat hätten versauern lassen, hätte das bei weitem nicht so viel.
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, wie durch ihren,
Effekt, den sie dadurch jetzt ähm bereitgestellt haben. Und muss man natürlich auch sagen, dieses Gutachten hat relativ krasse ähm,
Informationen, ne, die äh auch sehr eindeutig für die Öffentlichkeit äh zugänglich sein sollten.
Insofern herzlichen Glückwunsch an.
Frag den Staat, die vor allem sagen, wir haben Rechtsgeschichte geschrieben, weil ähm damit erstmals auch diese Idee der,
Zensur über Rechts mal sinnvoll äh angegriffen wurde. Vorher haben sie sich auf die Zitat Freiheit bezogen.
Sagen aber auch, das wird wahrscheinlich ähm in die nächste Instanz gehen,
äh Bundesamt für Risikobewertung hat bereits angedeutet, gegen diese Entscheidung des Landgerichts in Berufung gehen zu wollen.
Naja, ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt von der Effizienz und dem
unfassbaren hohen Output dieses Projektes. Also, was fragt den Staat jetzt schon alles auf den Weg gebracht hat und und äh locker gerüttelt hat. Das ist äh wirklich amazing.
Ja, das ist es auf jeden Fall und äh deswegen freuen wir uns auch jedes Mal, wenn Arne,
und das Team um fragt den Staat. Äh was Neues machen, was jeden Tag der Fall ist. Ähm
Wer auch was Neues macht, ist der Chaos-Computer-Club mit der Remote-Case Experience, die dieses Jahr zu der Zeit stattfindet, wo normalerweise ein wilder Kongress stattfinden würde. Wir haben den,
Käufer, partizipation, ja hier schon bei der letzten Sendung erwähnt, hier sei nur nochmal kurz darauf hingewiesen, dass er in einer Woche auch schon zu Ende ist, das heißt, wenn ihr dort einen Workshop, einen Vortrag oder sonstiges einreichen wollt, dann macht das,
jetzt so schnell wie möglich
und das Sticker Operation Center hat sich an uns gewendet und gebeten darauf hinzuweisen, dass es ein RC drei Sticker Exchange gibt. Ihr kennt sicherlich die Stickerboxen, die beim Kongress,
rumliegen, wo ihr die Aufkleber her habt.
Die auf euren Laptops sind und ähm ja wenn der Kongress ausfällt, heißt das natürlich nicht, dass ihr nicht trotzdem neue, geile Aufkleber tauschen könnt und ich meine
nichts ist peinlicher als nach dem Lockdown einfach noch mit den gleichen alten, langweiligen Stickern rumzurennen. Ähm insofern das äh Sticker-Operation Center,
bittet um Beteiligung und bietet an, dass ihr da mitmacht.
Das war, glaube ich, alles zur RC drei und damit werden wir auch schon am Ende oder Tim?
Ja, ich denke, das war's für heute. Kompakte Sendung, muss auch mal wieder sein.
Ja
Danke ich noch. Dann danke ich noch und zwar danke ich Kerstin, Peter, Nils, Oliver und Funzi.
Dafür, dass sie an mich gedacht haben und mir das Homeoffice verbessert haben. Vielen herzlichen Dank.
Und ich bedanke mich bei allen, die jetzt schon die Umstellung des Dauerauftrags veranlasst haben, es äh läuft so langsam an und,
jetzt nicht weiß, wovon die Rede ist, hört nochmal in die letzte Sendung äh rein. Da bin ich auf jeden Fall äh sehr dankbar für eure Zusammenarbeit,
Ja und jetzt äh entlassen wir euch. Das war's.
Bis dahin.
Bis nächste Woche, tschau.
Ciao, ciao.